[Music]
hey everybody I'm rich roll this is my
podcast or at least the visual version
of my podcast welcome to it it's the
show where I go deep and long with some
of the most intriguing interesting
people that I can find to have
conversations that I think are at least
I hope matter exploring all facets of
health human health emotional health
spiritual health planetary health and in
the case of today's show and today's
guest heart health
today's guest is dr. Kim Williams he is
the outgoing former president of the
American College of Cardiology now we're
going to sit down and we're gonna talk
about cardiovascular health because this
is truly the epidemic of our time of our
era one out of every three Americans
will die of heart disease about 800,000
Plus Americans die of a heart attack or
some form of cardiovascular disease
every single year but the thing is this
disease is easily preventable and often
reversible through some pretty simple
diet and lifestyle changes that's what
we're going to explore and I couldn't
think of a better person to walk us
through this incredibly important issue
than dr. Kim Williams his work is
inspiring and he is definitely a change
maker so sit back and enjoy my
conversation with
are you ready to go absolutely right
let's do it okay
dr. Williams it's a pleasure to finally
meet you thank you for carving out the
time to talk to me today certainly my
pleasure
is this your first time at this
conference or are you presented here
before I actually have presented yeah
yes a couple years ago and then I think
once before that uh-huh
I only got in last night so I missed
your talk yesterday
sorry not right what was that what was
the specific subject matter that you
spoke about so I wouldn't normally talk
about is heart heart disease and dying
and in the past I've always talked about
sort of vegan diet versus vegetarian
versus pesco vegetarian versus eating it
no real like you know beef and pork and
the like and and what is the data show
how is processor at need worse than red
meat which is worse than chicken which
is worse than fish which then it's sort
of the hierarchy of cardiovascular right
effects and this one is actually what's
going to be a fair amount of that from
other people and so what I proposed to
the plan trician folks got stole would
be that I'd actually talk about sugar
because there's just some work you Malay
ting so much more data on sugar mm-hmm
probably the the linchpin even though
there's data out there before the
linchpin was a an article in the Journal
of American Medical Association last
year that showed that the sugar Research
Foundation had actually paid some
researchers the influential people to
turn attention away from sugar for
cardiac disease in towards saturated fat
of course that was a good target but it
left lots of us people doing plant-based
nutrition eating a high amount of sugar
thinking that grows in the ground it's
okay doesn't have a mother doesn't have
a face
mm-hmm fits our criteria when it turns
out that the data was actually pretty
damaging well now there's actually been
a fair amount of sugar research and
correlation with everything all the
things that you would want there's a
good mechanism
that is the sugar increases your insulin
levels insulin increases plaque insulin
resistance makes it heap up on itself
and the next thing you know you've got
sugar addiction mm-hmm and you've got a
lot of sugar marketing and I then spoke
about the sort of the politics economics
the fact that our country actually does
have congressional support for farm
subsidies for production of high
fructose corn syrup mm-hmm and so we pay
them with text money to produce things
that make them inexpensive so that we
eat them more which increases the amount
of disease which we then pay for with
our Medicare system and right it's
really a circle that needs to be broken
now it's actually pointed out to me by
one of the Oregon congressmen I had no
idea until a couple years ago that this
was going on oh it's a huge problem it's
a huge problem and the repressed pricing
of these types of products including all
the processed snacks etc tend to
disproportionately impact the lower
socioeconomic strata of our culture
further you know further further
creating you know exaggerating the
divide between the haves and the
have-nots and and you know these people
end up getting more and more sick and
more and more dependent you did that
well you could have given myself yeah I
did talk about that I talked about SNAP
program healthy foods and hospitals how
we need to change a lot of things but
the SNAP program has really been sort of
the safety net for people and there was
an article published just a couple hours
before my talk that I was able to fit in
there talking about the important how
having a SNAP program that is having
access where you could actually go to a
grocery store and buy some decent food
mm-hmm actually decreases healthcare
costs by $1,400 per person per year
that's incredible numbers and what is
the current scope of how you can spend
those snap dollars because I know
traditionally it didn't apply to healthy
produce etc although I was doing a
podcast with I think it was Dan Buettner
the other day and he was saying that you
can now use snap dollars at your farmers
market is that true we well as far as I
know
but the other side of it it's what we've
been after that is we meaning the
American College of Cardiology and the
American Medical Association actually
passed a resolution pushing Congress and
regulators to change the SNAP program so
that you cannot buy unhealthy foods
mm-hmm and to try to make preferences
and so we we I think people are starting
to understand the impact of diet on our
society and the more data we accumulated
talking about health care costs and the
food choices that we make the better off
we're all gonna be yeah I think it's I
think it's happening I mean certainly
there's a tremendous amount of work to
be done that remains of course but let's
go back to the sugar thing for a minute
you know I think we as human beings are
reductionist by our very nature and the
scientific method is reductionist as
well by necessity I suppose but we
always want to look for you know that
one evil culprit like it's the sugar
it's the saturated fat it's the this
it's the bad and that's what we should
be sort of marshalling all our attention
and resources towards but obviously you
know that this is a incredibly complex
matrix of many factors that come into
play that contribute to things like
heart disease so when you're thinking
about sugar and when you're thinking
about saturated fat like how do you
explain these ideas to the patients that
come to see you
well there's first of all there's
certain allotted certainly a lot of data
that's impugning and supporting
saturated fat and this is a big fight
that people are having right I want to
get into this too so sorry but but the
interesting thing about it is that when
you're talking about saturated fat or
you're talking about cholesterol or the
new bad kid on the block heme iron that
is iron that should be good for you
except it came in a form of a red blood
cell and it's very toxic to your blood
vessels and making a heart attack stroke
and death and this is the this is the
iron that is contained in animal Aronnax
what exactly and exactly right and so so
it turns out that you've got all these
candidate genes if you want to call them
that for what is actually causing so
much of the differences between
plant-based nutrition and
the standard American diet for example
but those none of those things I just
mentioned are actually taken in
isolation sugar absolutely I mean you're
putting it in tea you're putting it in
coffee the data on tea is good they
don't coffee is even better but you're
putting it once you put sugar in it then
you're doing it in high amounts which
some people do you're actually
increasing everything from blood vessel
inflammation to the atherosclerosis and
so that's the one distinction and that
is it's really difficult to call out you
know saturated versus polyunsaturated
versus monounsaturated and you know if
you're overweight maybe you really
shouldn't and if you are you know
running and healthy in you know athletic
then you probably can tolerate more it
because you're gonna burn it as fuel but
sugar it's probably not good for us
under in under any circumstances there's
an idea out there that there's no
distinction between refined sugar and
the sugars that you find in fruit for
example so can you speak to that is
there a difference in how we metabolize
these things and the health impact when
you're talking about sugar what are you
talking about specifically if I can
borrow a term from new reductionism you
know we have to think of these things
than in the absence of like prospective
trials we think of them in terms of
mechanisms and so what I have in
preparation for this talk said the bad
guy here is insulin we know that people
would get when they get central obesity
they get insulin resistant they're in
their insulin levels are very high and
it's promoting more and more plaque and
therefore that's the thing that I would
like to control is the insulin level and
so that's one end took the fruit sugar
fructose the usual blood sugar that we
have glucose sucrose of course is the
table sugar that's the combination of
glucose and fructose and let's see what
happens when you have a dose of this and
increasing doses of it what happens to
your insulin level and I was able to
find a manuscript that detailed all of
this over time you take you know 50 or
25 50 100 grams see what happens and but
they did an interesting thing they
actually had a fourth thing in there and
it was actually white bread
and the insulin levels were with all
four we're about to the same and so the
idea that refined carbohydrates refined
grains are pretty much as bad as sugar
it's pretty much true as far as your
pancreas was concerned and production of
insulin right and and with respect to
when you're talking about that it made
me think of a conversation that I had
with dr. Neal Barnard was very adamant
that we should be looking more at the
fat intake in our diet and the impact of
that when it comes in the form of animal
products in our diet and how that
relates to the onset of type 2 diabetes
rather than all of this focus on sugar
so how do you think about that or do you
have a different point of view on that
then dr. Barnard well so Neil's a very
smart guy he reads a lot and I try to
read as much to catch up with them but
the fact is that I think that they're
both bad we actually that article that I
mentioned if people look it up the sugar
Research Foundation sugar industry in
the Journal of American Medical Medical
Association there was actually an
accompanying editorial that had this one
graph that everybody should see it's
country by country
cardiovascular disease mortality on the
one axis and a dot for sugar and a
consumption per capita and a dot for
saturated fat and the two of them for
every country they're in lost are in
lockstep it's Japan at the lowest United
States at the highest and all these
countries in between so I'm not sure
that we need to make a distinction I
think we just need to find out all that
we can about each element that's not
good for us whether it's heme iron or
sugar and then try to avoid them right I
mean looking at that from a correlative
point of view it's hard to parse the
distinctions between them right that's
right from a scientific perspective well
I think you know the average consumer
right now
you know it's and we're in an
interesting time there's so much
information available to everybody you
know with all of our devices etc but I
think it's also never
more important that we become more
discerning about the sources of the
information that we consume and there
are a lot of vested interests out there
that are heavily invested in making sure
that you remain confused and it is
confusing unless you're someone like
yourself who's really mining the data
and you know rolling up your sleeves and
really trying to understand what's going
on out here you can go online and you'll
see oh it's sugar oh it's fat oh it's
the saturated fat is back you know all
this discussion about saturated fat and
heart disease is nonsense and now we
know that saturated fat has no impact on
arterial cholesterol you know levels
increasing all of this so can you just
help me make sense of this for the
listener who's just trying to like make
better choices well it's not easy you
know they recalled several years ago 14
years ago when the portfolio diet came
out which end which was David Jenkins
it's a marvelous work and again Journal
of American Medical Association so not
you know vegan propaganda rag yeah I
mean this was a peer-reviewed
high-quality manuscript and it talked
just about inflammation and cholesterol
your LDL cholesterol and your c-reactive
protein what are the what is the
response to a statin versus a
plant-based diet mm-hmm wonderful
article and I figured that after you saw
that the LDL cholesterol the bad guy
goes down dramatically within two weeks
with both the statin and the diet the
plant-based diet and it had almonds it
had plant sterols and you know a soluble
fiber etc and then you looked at the
inflammation and they both went down but
the plant-based diet lowered it faster
then the statin did okay I figured that
that would take every capture everyone's
imaginations surest biochemical it's not
outcomes heart attack stroke and death
but it's pretty pretty important well
the response was actually not as much as
we would like and
the reason was one of the reasons was
that at the bottom you could see that it
was supported by the California almond
industry mm-hmm and part of the diet was
to do three handfuls of almonds every
day it doesn't mean it wasn't right
I'm sure is right I think it's a
wonderful guy you know but the it was a
good lesson
to me early on to try to stay away from
industry influence as much as possible
right and so we have had just what
you're saying confusion I fight we're
gonna pick one it would I'd be concerned
about the egg board and saying that
cholesterol is not a nutrient of concern
which actually came out in the Dietary
Guidelines for Americans early in 2015
we were able to show them up that is
Health and Human Services and the USDA
who sort of partnered together to put
that document it's together and run the
dietary Advisory Group we did get them
to change it we showed them all the
literature Neal Barnard was very helpful
in there but you're realizing that
you've got to have science that's that's
pure that's independent so that no one's
best at interest it's interesting
everybody asked me well when is your
book coming out and that's one of the
reasons I don't want to I mean there's
plenty of books out there a great books
and the other is I never want somebody
to say that I have a vested interest
other than my own right you're just
trying to show books
exactly right never that it's always
gonna be about my patients about my
family about my country and that's
that's what it's about
yeah well I think you know first two
things first of all that was a quite a
victory for the ACC when you were
president right getting that you know
getting those nutritional guidelines
shifted with respect to cholesterol so
you know that I thought they left out
the punch line yeah what the bottom line
of in the document it actually says
which is a quote from the Institute of
Medicine not ACC it said that people
should eat as little cholesterol as zero
oh I'm sorry a little class of
cholesterol as possible which of course
I interpret in my brain tonight as I
just did at zero which means you pretty
much have to be a vegan because there's
only you know how many animal products
don't have cholesterol I think a quites
jello and
about it right well let's talk a little
bit about I mean the second point I was
gonna make was that you know we're in a
capitalist society and you know it costs
money to perform this research and
somebody's got to pay for it right so
aside from grant money or however else
you know these studies get funded
industry is sitting there you know
willing and ready to fund these things
and that comes with its whole you know
bag of compromises obviously but to see
our way forward I mean do we need new
ways of funding these studies like how
can objective studies get performed in a
way that in a way such that they're not
compromised by industry interests a lot
has occurred over the last few years the
development of data safety monitoring
boards for example where people who are
completely independent of the study they
are paid by industry which is a funny
thing because they're paid to block them
well if things are going badly in the
study and yet that's considered a
relationship with industry with
something we ought to think through I
think but we also have you know Clint
clinical trials.gov
where people if they're gonna do a big
clinical trial they should submit it
everyone can review it and so there's
more of a truth than there was before if
I could point to one issue with the
industry sponsored trials in the past
and that's it's really not just industry
it's all of us it's the positive
publication bias we see for example heme
iron suppose there were you know five
investigators out there and four of them
found that there was no relationship
between heme iron and heart attack
stroke and death and one of them did
before if they submit it is a negative
study it may not get published because
it's not scintillating but also us as
investigators when we do a negative
trial and say oh well that didn't work
and we move on to the next thing they
might not even submit it hmm whereas the
one that found the relationship they're
going to publish it so it brings up the
whole question of
no this public this positive publication
bias really brings up the question of
all of the things that we're doing and
why we would like to have large
prospective registered randomized trials
so since that's been happening we
actually are getting data you know yeah
and in pretty much every area
everyone knows the the acronym for the
trial and you will wait for the results
you know you have a presentation on what
the methodology is and then two or five
years later you get a big result and
it's positive or negative and everybody
knows about it now so that's I think
it's been an improvement and it's it
mitigates the industry influence because
they can't cherry-pick right what's
gonna get published and what's not right
much ado has been made in over the past
a year about this idea that saturated
fat is back lots of articles being
written about everything you thought
about saturated fat is wrong we don't
need to worry about this anymore it's
your new best friend
knock yourself out with bacon and eggs
so when you read that when you see that
what what happens with you so there's so
many responses but I'll try not to recap
too much of what I said already but just
a couple of highlights one is we just
don't take the Crisco put it in a pan
heat it up and then drink it okay so
whenever we're getting saturated fat
it's with something else that probably
isn't good for you and it might be heme
iron it might be cholesterol and it
might be just animal protein itself and
it's you know the fact that that
promotes cancer growth so we have to
take everything I start to say with a
grain of salt but that might not be the
best thing to do either but we have to
try to look at the research that you
know that what they're really doing
typically is is doing food frequency
questionnaire x' and then analyzing the
components of what people said they ate
and then trying to correlate that with
outcomes and that is just very difficult
you're making several assumptions along
the way and you're not really capturing
the the whole team of things that are
potentially damaging and so to pick out
each one and then get reliable results
every time may be difficult so the best
example I think is the pure trial
and that's the one that everyone's
talking about slim Yousef is a good
friend of mine and you know we happen to
be at a dinner at the European Society
of Cardiology and the day that his
article came out sadden talked to him
for a while about this and my concerns
that you really weren't capturing the
vegetarian population which meant that
you were actually comparing things that
were not healthy necessarily from one
population to the next and then 19
different countries and that it's not
not the same kind of fat that we're
getting United States okay so you know
he had he defended it well he said there
were some small vegetarian populations
in the 19 countries but they don't
overwhelm the data so Mike my biggest
concern about the peer trial is that and
I probably should have might run it by
and the next time I see him is you know
a actually is a pretty darn good job of
categorizing the fat saturated
polyunsaturated monounsaturated but the
carbohydrates were not characterized
that I could find it anyway I bet he has
an appendix somewhere where he can
explain that because I have just as you
know from my interest in sugar
carbohydrates are not all carbohydrates
and so when you're talking about complex
carbohydrates that are not gonna drive
up your insulin levels you're probably
doing something that you you can burn as
fuel it's not going to be you know anti
it's not gonna be inflammatory it's not
promoting and rise in your cholesterol
and increasing plaque formation that is
completely different than having a
sugary refined flour type of body
response and so it wouldn't surprise me
that saturated fat it falls second to
carbohydrates if they're refined
carbohydrates in terms of the damages
that they can do right and so we really
need to have good comparisons of healthy
foods so none of that was talking about
whole food plant-based diet and the last
comment is I borrow for I think from
Giuliana haver you probably know who's
sure I know yeah yeah you tell me who
said this originally but the fat you eat
is the fat you wear that is such an
important concept that and I know the
American Heart Association did a
wonderful job by the way
a few months I think last May of doing a
presidential advisory where they
reviewed all of the available literature
on saturated fat and came to the
conclusion that you really should need
it based on the literature they also
actually made a slightly controversial
statement which was that you probably
shouldn't eat coconut fat either because
that's has so much saturated fat and it
compared to other vegetables and I know
they got a lot of pushback from it I
know they're there and this interesting
that the presidential advisory was one
guy dr. Steven Hauser who's wonderful
guy and then John Warner who took over
as president so I got the blame just
because of writing that they switched in
so but you know what what can you do
about that the they have the right to
review all of the literature and make an
expert opinion and say that that's what
it is it's an expert opinion nothing
definitive and all that does is invite
us to do studies and if there are people
I know David Katz thinks Yale thinks
that coconut oil is really good I don't
have enough data that make a conclusion
myself let's do some trials and right up
with whether or not it's damaging or not
yeah I think a lot of people would like
to know the answer to that I mean what I
my understanding and correct me if this
is incorrect is that the the saturated
fat in coconut oil is comprised in large
part by lauric acid which is a more
easily metabolized version of saturated
fat a more readily available source of
energy burning fuel versus the set so
there's different kinds of there's not
just one saturated there's different
kinds of this right like okay this is
not click baby stuff like you got a
really you know dig into it and
understand that this is highly nuanced
and you've devoted your whole life to
this well this part is I'm much more of
a nuclear guy so I thought I was gonna
spend my life doing cardiology and
nuclear physics at the same time and now
I'm in nutrition but I am a fan of all
of that and and yes the the H a report
actually goes into that and talks about
something that I didn't know that the
fetch weed is the fat you wear but more
so of its animal fat that is the
vegetable saturated fat for the reasons
you said that shorter chains there's
less calories in it
so it actually is better for you but is
it good for you that's right question
right right right I bet that we don't
know yeah interesting so you are the
outgoing president of the ACCC there was
a one-year tenure yep yeah 2015 to 2016
so so let's talk a little bit about that
organization and what the kind of
mission statement and purpose of it is
and you know what your your your goals
were during that period of time and and
other than what we already mentioned you
know what was accomplished well it's it
certainly is a growing organization that
is dedicated to making sure that people
do better in terms of their heart health
so the mission actually is to improve
heart health and transform
cardiovascular care and the two go
hand-in-hand what we really are meaning
is to try and add more members add more
member of Araya teas and so we have
53,000 members or so right now it used
to be cardiologists now it's then it
became cardiologists and nurse
practitioners and then it became
pharmacist and then we started doing
international and so anyone who's
interested in improving heart health and
is as part of the team and we work right
now on a lot of issues that are facing
the cardiovascular field prevention is
one of them and so I would say that
during my year we focused a little more
than we had in the past on population
health it was interesting to have
meetings on population health have
experts come all from all over to
Washington DC to the heart house and
discuss how we can make things better
and it's you know everyone's sort of
looking kind of you know out of the
corner there are saying wire
cardiologists trying to decrease their
income just because we feel like this is
our job isn't that the core goal here I
think you said there was I saw a quote
from you like my job is to hook
cardiologists out of business
that's exactly right and you know it
would take a while and I have to say
that it's it's timely it would be great
if other organizations were focused on
these things as much as we do because
and you know inside and outside of
medicine because
last year was the first time in 40 years
that cardiovascular disease deaths in
the country went up hmm and that is just
something that we just can't abide by
you know they've new we're always
bragging about this decreasing curve
about 50% over 40 years and
cardiovascular mortality and it's bypass
surgery and statins and beta blockers
and AIDS and they were all these
medications for heart failure and
decreasing sudden death because we put
into fib relators that shocked people
when they when they have a fatal
arrhythmia and they come back to life
and we were so proud of all this stuff
and then the American population somehow
has overcome no matter what you do
exactly yeah and when the CDC put those
numbers out there they said it was
obesity and diabetes that's driving it
and that's a nutrition and so at all the
fundamental issue that we've been
dealing with for the last so many years
is really at the core of all we do and
it will uproot and and undo any success
that we can do with devices and
medications yeah it's got to be a shift
in priorities and focus because it is
amazing to reduce by 50% the mortality
rate of people who are suffering from
heart disease as a result of all this
amazing science and technology but if
that comes at the cost of really
addressing the fact that the incidence
of people who are you know you know
becoming patients in the first place
then you're you're waging a losing war
ultimately yeah everyone's gonna get
older and they're gonna pass away at
some point wouldn't it be nice if we
were as healthy as possible until that
happened and not you know I have these
chronic diseases that are completely
avoidable by you know by lifestyle yeah
I mean we need to be talking about
prevention and we need to be creating
systems that promote prevention I mean
we're seeing it with the rise of
functional medicine clinics and doctors
who really are up to speed and paying
attention to these things and but you
know it's tough when we have a structure
that's set up that allows
well-intentioned doctors only 15 minutes
with a patient and they're incentivized
to just diagnose and
scribe and move on to the next thing
like we're never gonna you know crack
the code that's going till we really get
to the core of how the whole you know
system functions that's right so getting
back to what the college does so then
the population health is just one small
aspect we actually are a global
organization we have 40 chapters
international chapters where a chapter
can be formed whenever there's members
who are have obtained a high level of
proficiency they're called Fellows of
the American College of Cardiology if
you have 20 fellows in any area you can
have a chapter and then it has a
governor which then participates in the
governance of the college no no taxation
without representation right and so it
turns out that we have collectively
learned a lot you know we have our
members and Lebanon for example are
dealing with smoking and very young
people you know heart failure in Brazil
and it's not just the Chagas disease
infection that people can google and say
oh my gosh this people get an infection
in their heart you know disappears yes
they also have hypertension at a high
rate the diabetes in Mexico and then the
obesity in the United States and we can
all learn from each other about how to
improve outcomes so the international
mission I think is is is key to success
for us we also do a lot of hospital
accreditation in terms of making sure
that if you're gonna go in for an
angiogram you're going to in a places
that's that knows what they're doing and
they've demonstrated it and and they're
probably our biggest product nowadays is
the registries of the National
cardiovascular data registry and CDR it
collects information on all the
important diseases you have a
defibrillator are your people your
people putting and defibrillators when
they need it if you have atrial
fibrillation are you getting the right
medication for it and so a lot of
disease management so with that you
would think that we cover the globe
literally in Figure and literally and
geographically and as well as
figuratively but we do feel that all of
these things should be reduced and we're
managing things said that can be
prevented and so let's continue to focus
on that and we'll try to continue
putting that influence out there right
very good and was that was your
presidency is that a like an appointed
thing or an elected thing like how does
that work how did that work it actually
is an election election it's an election
by a nomination committee that reviews
all the people who are applicants who
have been leaders who and it's in my
case it was other people asking me to
run and I'm saying I don't know if I can
do this just just there's a politician
well it's a the politics was fine
actually you know there was a time when
I was very much interested in the
political side I've been an advocacy
person for a while always going to
Congress talking about how to improve
outcomes for everything and you know
like hospital food that's one of our
what that's something we're on right now
let's legislate that hospital food has
to be healthy and we actually got that
through the American Medical Association
so I I know I'm tange ending here but
god I'll give an example yeah and the it
was such an impressive outpouring we
were a little nervous s at college it
was actually Neal Barnard who was -
started it and when the in the
Washington DC chapter of the AMA and you
know we had there were people at the
college who were nervous that you know
we're gonna step on everyone's toes but
ultimately we've went on ahead and
supported it and pushed it and what's
the resistance to that so the issue is
that you're going to make an enemy
somewhere and so you're always looking
for unintended consequences it's
politics in a way right right okay and
suppose for example and I don't think
this would happen but suppose for
example the American Hospital
Association said that you know the this
you know this program you're doing is
disenfranchising our hospitals therefore
we're not gonna use anymore ACC products
yeah which is then gonna hurt our
patients okay so I mean so you right
you're trying to balance everything and
so but at the end of the day you realize
that it's just the right thing to do you
know and damn the torpedoes we're gonna
go ahead and so so I you know along with
Neil and I thought we were gonna be
alone at the microphone and sure
I am a delegates were lined up outside
the door trying to talk about the the
ravages of the hospital food now there
are most of them were actually
plant-based all of them were concerned
cardiologists coming up to the mic
saying I just put a stent I just put
three stents in this person and bring
them back to the CCU I come around on
them and you've given them bacon and
eggs and the McDonald's in the lobby
right absolutely and so this is
something that that we really are taking
on and we'd like to improve I know it's
gonna decrease our income but it's going
to improve aren't the outcomes of our
patients and that's wonderful that's
what we're really about
yeah that's great have you done similar
have yet similar initiatives with school
lunch so odd year you know it's the the
if there's two things that happen with
one about five years ago there was a
pilot in our Northern California Chapter
of the ACC that a pilot that they were
supporting that they were very proud of
where they had gone into schools and
removed the junk food and put in carrots
of celery and it said that it had an
amazing impact and the kids actually
started to like the more healthy foods
they were making more healthy food
choices and that it's by their
assessment they were making more healthy
food she was choices at home so that
actually I think may have influenced
FLOTUS given the First Lady of the
United States and they were actually she
sent a representative to our population
health meeting at the American College
of Cardiology to talk specifically about
the F and D program I did see the Jim
Jimmy Kimmel sort of they they had a
good job yeah yeah
joking relationship and in Kimmel would
say well you tried less move and nobody
did okay so so let's go FNV except you
got to change the name yes it doesn't
sound right and though they go back and
forth but I think they got the point
across their fruits and vegetables were
the way that people were supposed to go
and so it would have been nice to have
that program that kind of program I
think they were starting in Norfolk
Virginia I haven't seen an outcome for
Deb eschmeyer was her food czar who was
very helpful in getting that and very
helpful to us when we were fighting this
you know dietary guideline thing I don't
know where that's gonna go I know a lot
of the things that in the Obama
administration of being reversed it'd be
good to see what what actually happens
in terms of school foods mm-hmm so you
famously adopt a plant-based diet in
2003 spent about 15 years right so so
let's talk about that like what prompted
that you know how did you make that
decision so it's interesting that this
in in retrospect I mean you make a
decision and then you can look back on
it later and try to figure out what led
to that and I'm I was able to identify a
few key things one that I don't talk
about very much was my affiliation with
the association of black cardiologists
and there was one cardiologists in that
organization his name was Tazewell banks
and Tazewell was always talking about
diet and he was always talking about
Dean Ornish and he had seen the the life
trials and read them pay attention to
them changed his diet and he was
director of the coronary care unit and
EC General Hospital part of Howard
University and he was claimed he made
this outlandish claim that every person
came in there with a heart attack he
changed their diet that moment to
vegetarian diet he made sure that they
understood it before they left and then
they'd stick to it and he had followed
everyone for at least one year and no
one had a recurrent heart attack this
was back in the days when recurrent
heart attacks was actually quite
frequent so how many years ago was this
so that would have been probably the mid
1980s it was not too long after some of
Dean Ornish's first studies were out
there so that was in the back of my mind
because I had actually heard that and
then being a nuclear cardiologist I had
actually seen the the land schooled Dean
Ornish PET scans with rubidium 82
rubidium 82 is an isotope that you do
PET scanning with I didn't turns out
that that actually was my research when
I was a cardiology fellow was in
rubidium 82 so everything with rubidium
I to always take a look at him
and so I'd seen those images where in
three months
the blood flow dramatically improves and
you know is can that really happen so I
put it in the back of my mind and then
right before I went to that American
College of Cardiology meeting where I
had the cholesterol test in the context
of though getting a little older and
having my son who was a nationally
ranked tennis player and I was his coach
and he had aged out and he was going to
you know play baseball at Valparaiso
University and I wasn't on the tennis
court twice a day every day that change
in lifestyle and continuing that diet of
chicken and fish which we thought were
healthy back then but if I had just done
the literature search I would have seen
that that actually was high in
cholesterol right so that's a common
misunderstanding exactly and you know
there are some relative benefits know if
you're compared to process with me
that's way better it's a little better
than red meat but it's still not
vegetables in terms of mortality right
so you're eating this diet look I mean
good I'm not eating processed meat
something any red meat I'm eating my
chicken and my fish and I'm treating it
clean and you know I'm doing what I'm
supposed to do that's right and so in
that context I'm on my way to this
meeting and where this is about to
happen to me where I get the blood tests
done and there was a lady who came to my
lab my nuclear lab and I was the reader
that day who actually had a scan that
looked pretty good but as usual I looked
through the chart and I see that there's
an old skin so I pull it up and I'm
comparing him and it's dramatically
improved this wasn't this was the study
the first one which had been about six
months earlier had a tremendous amount
of blood flow problems she must have had
I figured three vessel disease and that
those festivals were pretty tight okay
so I'm looking on our little worksheet
because we you know my nuclear lab that
I created that University of Chicago is
you know we just collected data on
everything every little thing was in the
report that you would ever want to know
and there was something missing it was
the bypass surgery what happened to the
bypass surgery what happened to the
stenting you would had a stent probably
five vessels I figured no one to do that
she probably went to bypass surgery how
did it get so much better and so in the
absence of any data that they could that
they collected I actually called the
patient I said sorry to bother you but I
think my lab left out something okay
did you get bite when was the bypass
surgery or the stent and she says no
they told me about it they told me I
needed it but I refused I looked on the
line and I found Dean Ornish's program
and I went on this diet and started
exercising and it took about six weeks
for my chest pain to go away I would
never do that by the way okay I would do
the Dean artists and the stenting and
six weeks of chest pain is probably not
what we're recommending but she lost a
lot of weight and she was exercising so
well that she was training for like a 5k
or a 10k she was just doing so well and
she tripped on a curb and broke her
ankle and so that's why she was back in
the lab because there's she is refusing
an angiogram had not gotten the standard
treatment and now she's got to go to the
operating room for an elective surgery
and everyone's afraid there's problem
patient Oh Mike well Coast's anesthesia
does not want to put you to sleep with
untreated heart disease and so it really
was a fantastic story and the idea that
the Ornish diet could be just as good as
the scans that I was saying routinely
after bypass surgery after stenting was
very impressive and then fortunately I
had my cholesterol done and then a next
couple of days after that and right see
your LDL was like 170 it was 170 I
didn't actually believe it I thought you
know this was back in the day where we
had the exhibitors on the floor in the
meeting okay and you going exhibit Hong
you stand in line you get your
cholesterol tested for free great I
thought it was a plot to sell
cardiologists statins so I went to their
competitor and it was 169 so then I
fasted all night okay
came in the next morning that's so funny
than know it was wrong to figure this
out exactly so after fasting all night
it was still 169 and so I stopped eating
animals right at that day and it never
went back wow that's amazing and you you
wrote about this you wrote this
it was on like what's that cycle like
med med page today or something like
that I actually couldn't read it because
I'm not a member or what I couldn't log
in to read it but you kind of talk about
why you made this decision right the
reasons that supported it you know the
history leading up to it and it caused
quite a stir you had as many fans as
detractors right and there's a lot of
think pieces written about this and
given your you know your position as you
know president of the American College
of Cardiology kind of foisted you into
the spotlight in a big way so there was
there was a very bright light being
shined upon you and this decision what
is he actually saying he's a member of
this vegan propaganda unit he's
advancing some industry you know
interest I don't know what's going on
here alright but there was a lot of you
know there's a lot of discussion about
this right so you know how did you you
know whether that navigate that and how
do you kind of perceive that now in
retrospect well you know it's an
interesting story in that it was
actually a staffer in the American
College of Cardiology PR department the
media department you noticed that I was
eating different and always asking for
different food and the meetings and said
well why don't why are you doing that
since it said heart attack stroke and
death and she said well why don't we put
that in our block you know and do a
little nutrition prevention page so I
said okay that's fine and then that got
picked up by met page today I said okay
then that got picked up by the New York
Times and the next thing you know it's
all over the place and Dean Ornish came
to my rescue at that page today and rode
dice they asked them if he couldn't
write a because there's a like a 400
word lemma and he says you know can I
write a substantial piece to talk about
the data that made him do this and so
that became a wonderful companion piece
and a lot
people looked at I didn't you're quite
correct I was accused of you know the
industry influence and pushing someone's
you know agenda that's really just about
my LDL cholesterol then I found out all
the other stuff that that happens
because a lot of the publication's
weren't out there in 2003 but the data
is out there now animal protein is bad
for you heme iron is bad for you the
cholesterol the igf-1 in the animal
protein this is this is all science and
so the difference is now I read it now
the other major controversy which I
probably shouldn't repeat one more time
but I guess I'll commit to it was making
that comment which was completely half
joking but I was making a statement
about cardiovascular research and the
fact that nutrition research is
typically in the American Journal of
Clinical Nutrition it's not in the
Journal of American College of
Cardiology so much and so it's not in
front of the cardiologists and so I made
that statement again more than half
joking the statement that that yeah why
don't you you say it right two kinds of
cardiologists Vicens and those who
haven't read the data uh-huh no a little
trouble yeah it did well the interesting
part is that you know it's wit like like
like they say if you take the text out
of the context then all you're left to
put this the con and so people were
misunderstanding I thought I'm throwing
all my colleagues under the bus when I'm
really claiming or asking for more
research more review articles more
little more data to go into cardiology
journals so that people are actually
seeing it then they can influence that
their lives and their patients but then
two things started happening one is the
you know the pushback from that was
actually they've I think most people
understood that I was saying that if
they know me at all and they don't know
me they they wouldn't say anything to me
if they did know me they knew that I was
you know it's saying that in a joke in a
jocular manner but there were some
people who took it seriously
particularly at rush where you know I'm
the chief of cardiology and we now have
you know nine Deacon cardiologists some
people
people looked at the data and they saw
them yeah this is probably something I
shouldn't be eating and they've they've
changed their own lifestyle which is
wonderful because it gives us a good
cadre of people who work on prevention
the other thing that happened though I
have to say is that I'd spent six years
on the American Board of Internal
Medicine doing the cardiology exam and
then the ACC leadership position folks
so I'm seeing a lot of cardiologists
then my time at the American side and
nuclear cardiology I was a president 12
years ago each one of those
organizations has had some luminary
person who died of heart disease and I'm
kind of saying that's where we really
need to start that is in order to fix
the population through all the powers of
our accha guidelines the the people who
were actually getting that data out
there and putting it in the hands of
patients and the prescriptions and
telling people what how they should live
this cardiology so at this point I've
had an enough of the sudden cardiac
deaths I'm actually my new goal is to
not retire until the leading cause of
death and cardiologists is no longer
heart disease and so it's amazing that
it it precipitates at that level amongst
you know amongst your peers he's on some
level it's like you can't transmit
something you haven't got like if you're
if you're not living this life in a
certain way where you're you know where
you're an embodiment of the message that
you're promoting that's inherently
problematic right so I really has
affected me in terms of the guilt when
one of my friends would pass away you
know they knew that I was eating
different I ate with them they knew that
I was getting different and did I say
anything and did I say it loud enough
and so now in equip that I can come up
with it gets on Fridays today or Twitter
I'm fine with I'll take the backlash if
it's gonna save some of my colleagues
lives ultimately that will help our
country you know that will help reduce
this this terrible epidemic of heart
disease even if it makes me unpopular we
should point out that your LDL went down
from 170 to 90
yeah how long did that take well you
know according to David Jenkins it
probably took two weeks but I measured
it at six weeks
ah but you know a nothing yeah yeah it's
interesting and and I you know statins
do work that fast diet works that fast
they both can precipitously drop the
cholesterol in a matter of days really
and so it's interesting that there's
there's a lot of confusion about the
amount of research on diet and
cholesterol that people really need to
understand and so why was I so that
people will say oh you're that one of
those 25 percent who are hyper
responders well that may be true but
more than likely it's just the fact that
I was eating a certain amount of high
cholesterol food and then I decrease it
dramatically and you could see that fall
the thing that is confused most of the
diet research on this is the idea of
saturation of the receptors meaning you
can only absorb so much cholesterol
you're making some in your liver and
then you eat some and you can only
absorb so much and so when someone tests
a regular American diet which has a lot
of cholesterol in it and then they say
I'm gonna give you zero or one egg and
then four and then we're gonna do a
cross over and you know it's three weeks
or something and you're gonna do two
eggs every day the cholesterol
difference of those two diets is
tremendously different okay but the
amount of absorption of that extra
cholesterol is small because you already
got all this baseline cholesterol so
what I think everyone would say is that
we're all pretty much human and and that
that's saturation of the receptor
phenomena that is you can only take up
so much if you're if you're eating a lot
of cholesterol you eat more it makes
mutton very little different if you're
not eating a lot of cholesterol and you
eat and and you stop your cholesterol
goes down right yes so it's not a
one-to-one ratio of dietary cholesterol
to blood cholesterol it's much right
right right yeah that's interesting I
think what you said about you
the responsibility that you feel that
kind of you know speak to these issues
in light of you know having colleagues
that have passed away is an interesting
one it's like how do you like what is
the best strategy to be as helpful as
possible to people who are in need you
know are you the person who's gonna like
browbeat somebody are you just gonna be
a lighthouse and stand in the light and
wait for people that come to you is it
some you know is somewhere in between
those two things but I think being
mindful or having an understanding of
how you best communicate is really
important right like in a yourself being
somebody who you know is somebody of
high stature within you know within this
field that is directly relevant to this
problem I would assume that that makes
you feel compelled to you know speak a
little bit louder then then then perhaps
somebody else I think you're right at
the end of being compelled now after but
the CIM compels me really is the bad
outcomes and that's for patients that's
for family it's for colleagues well and
I really am a believer that every person
and that's whether I'm in the clinic
dealing with patients or talking to
colleagues everyone's different you have
to kind of deal with people where they
are and there are some people who are
interested some people who are not
interested our job is to try to increase
their interest and their investment in
changing their health outcome and so I
think it takes a wide variety of
strategies and some people you just hand
them an article general American Medical
Association on August 1st 2016
animal protein kills you doesn't matter
which kind and in terms of increasing
death but each one kills you in a
different rate processor had meat much
worse than etc etc that article is so
easy to hand out to people and it can
change their behavior right one person
will just be like that's all I need I'm
done I'm making the changes the other
person's like well I might just prefer
to go to my grave eating unhealthy food
and I've heard that with that guy oh
well you know actually I've sat next to
him you know three nights ago at the
owner mer
can Congress of cardiology in in Panama
City and it's a wonderful cardiologist I
won't say his name of course I feel and
he won't listen to this net this yeah
yeah but he was saying that you know he
saw my my talk in Panama City on diet
and mortality and eating animals and he
says no I will never change that I just
won't do it and it's that and that's
I've had patients say that to me
the mortality rate of people saying that
to me is pretty high but that that's
talking about you know people who are
who have disease in a clinic so I would
say that everyone is going to require
something difference and you're not
going to get a hundred percent but I
could say two things one is the
groundswell of everyone coming together
from different points of view so I know
you've been in Australia right what I
noticed about our car plant-based
nutrition
colleagues in Australia is that there's
a little less cardiology a little more
animal rights okay a little more
environment and we have that in the
United States as well and I think
everyone coming from different angles to
try to solve this are we're going to
help each other the other observation is
the power of media like what you're
doing right now the number of people who
have walked up to me and I saw your
twenty seconds and in what the health
and I saw I saw your 90 seconds and
eating you alive and I really appreciate
what what you did and I haven't eaten an
animal since I saw that movie and that
really it's really encouraging yeah it's
gonna make a difference so so I should
be interviewing you and congratulating
you on getting out there and and getting
the message to people well I appreciate
that but you know you're you're doing
the hard work you know you're doing the
important work and and you know and
you're the man behind the science that
supports all of this and I think you're
right we need all voices you know you
need the hardcore protester who's you
know storming in the streets and you
need the quiet person in the corner like
all of these voices are important the
environmental the animal right like they
all there's an interplay here and I
think the more variation we have then
the more opportunity you have for
somebody to connect with one of those
voices right because everybody is
different like you said
so when you have these patients come
into your into your office and you do an
intake or whatever and you're trying to
figure out like okay what's gonna
motivate this person you know I've
spoken to doctors like Robert Oz felt or
you know dr. McMackin and they'll
actually an even joke on like though
they'll actually you know write out a
prescription pad like eat vegetables and
they'll hand them a DVD of what the
health or Forks Over knives or something
like that like how do you you know what
is your protocol so this interesting
that we have the benefit which I know a
lot of physicians my age do not like
this benefit of the electronic
electronic health record everything has
to go in this electronic system so I'm
sitting in front of the patient I'm
sitting at 45 degrees but they can see
the screen - uh-huh and so I actually
pull up this the same eye sometimes well
actually if it's of someone particularly
highly educated I actually stick in my
jump drive with the slides on it and I
start giving them my talk I know it's no
I it's the luxury of being chief of
cardiology let me give you my key now
and and it really resonates with people
to see the data because most of my talk
is just this article and then that
article in the other and so it's all
data and they can choose to not respond
to it but you while I'm giving them this
data and after I've assessed you know
where they are educationally which is
important to try to make sure that
you're speaking and where they can
understand one of the things that we
have to do is we take a food intake
questionnaire and find out where they
are right now mm-hmm
and how much change do they really need
to make and then you know I have to
admit I do a lot of transition diet and
stuff because I've seen just you know I
don't have randomized trials on it but
it started off with the fact that the
transition diet by that I mean like
veggie burgers veggie hotdogs veggie
stuff the kind of stuff you get a Tiger
Stadium right right right yeah bridges
just get them used to a different way
well it actually what it really does is
just that stops the animals and so these
you know you know I get a lot of friends
and even family saying you know you
really shouldn't be eating veggie bacon
it's like
gets processed well we have a lot of
data on process me and I'm still looking
for the data on process vegetables every
time I hear something process it seems
to get absorbed a little better but you
might be missing nutrients and stuff
like that should that you could be I
would host that somebody does that
research in the meantime what's
happening is there's their cholesterol
is going down their weight is going down
the blood pressures going down because
all of these you know veggie products
are full of veggie protein which lowers
blood pressure so I'm reaching my goals
in terms of their health care and for
specifically for cardiology that seems
to be the easiest switch to pull that is
to find it whatever it is you tell me an
animal product and I will find a
vegetarian substitute and it could be
you know the veggie cheese made out of
chickpeas which is fairly common and you
know they and you know will obviously
down the road these products will be out
there because they're increasing so
rapidly which means the uptake must be
good this is a capitalistic society that
wouldn't if they weren't successful
products see they wouldn't do well so
I'm saying that we should be researching
them and finding out if there's benefits
or not or to all this process stuff it
doesn't sound like the best thing to do
but I can tell you it's better than
animals yeah yeah yeah well it's never
been easier to find these products right
and it's getting better every day every
store pet store has them yeah
which also means it's never been easier
to be an unhealthy vegan you know right
well we're very particular about that I
I'm glad you mentioned that there's been
loads of literature coming out we had a
recent high-profile article in the
Journal of American cardiology talking
specifically about unhealthful
plant-based diet and they actually made
an index of how many of these refined
carbs and sugar and the like and there
was a correlation with death and so
let's let's try and have more fruits and
vegetables and less of this the stuff I
don't know how you would characterize a
veggie hot dog you know I mean or a
veggie burger right like what the food
group does this fall under well I you
know it's but but is it healthier if not
healthy we'd
actually have data we have data that
says you know you can get a vegan
doughnut that is not healthy if doesn't
matter at this vegan or not it's not
healthy but we don't have good data on
you know we know sure you can say potato
chips it's fried and so you know we
there's certain amount of data that we
have and then data that we don't right
how are we how are we going to better
address serving the people that need
this information the most you know we
touched on earlier this socio-economic
divide and we're in a culture in which
you know wellness or being vegan
quote-unquote vegan seems to be the
purview of the well-heeled who can do
all their shopping at Whole Foods and
meanwhile we have millions of people
living in food deserts and these are the
people who are suffering the most from
these chronic ailments and we need to
figure out strategies in ways for
penetrating these communities and
serving them better and I know this is
something that you care a lot about and
have to put a lot of thought into well
it's not an easy issue these are the
areas that I grew up in and South Side
of Chicago and the west side of Chicago
it's where I work now at Rush University
I have to mention you know I have to
shout out to rush
they even before I got there there was a
interest in the community that is not
financially motivated they were actually
spending hard-earned dollars to go and
set up programs to try to take care of
people do primary care and places that
you probably wouldn't want to walk you
know and at night the neighborhoods on
the west side particularly as a South
Sider but as it turns out all of this
hard work is going to be improved even
further if we can have programs where
people will get education and so I've
actually gone to the west side community
centers and given talks and I've been in
the churches giving informational talks
about diet that have improved some of
their outcomes on the one hand then we
have a couple other major programs one
of them in cardiology called the heart
program the heart standing for a hell
being everyone assess risk today uh-huh
okay I got it
I wonder what Jimmy Kimmel would think
of that I tried hard coming up with that
algorithm it's pretty good so it
actually is playing off of the fact that
the American College of Cardiology and
the American Heart Association put out a
risk calculator it's an app that anybody
can get off of the app store and you put
in all your numbers and it tells you
what your ten-year risk of having a
cardiac event is and so will go into a
church and we will set up booths where
we measure a finger stick cholesterol
and a finger stick hemoglobin a1c that's
the fancy way of telling you whether or
not you have diabetes and or
pre-diabetes and do the blood pressure
fill out the form
you know age gender black or white and
once you have that data in there it
comes up with a number of what your risk
is and then you can have a discussion
you can have a real discussion if you
change these things in your lifestyle
you can reduce that risk if you don't
reduce that risk you probably should be
on a statin or medication until you can
because your that's a you know if your
risk is high now the other program
that's very popular at rush is called
the alive program and that is run by our
prevention colleagues and they actually
go into churches they've gotta they've
been doing it on the mostly on the west
side of Chicago and they actually do six
weeks of studies sort of a Bible based
health food approach I'm hoping that we
can partner with them I can see this you
know heart a live heart sandwich where
we go in see what the risk is see what
the effect of their educational program
is by measuring it after the fact so
anyway obviously when I'm describing
sort of granular details about our you
know our overall strategy of trying to
impact the community it's not just
sitting there on the west side you know
hoping that you know everybody will come
in from the server's we are actually we
do want people to come in from the
suburbs and they do because Russia's
highly ranked and it's a top clinical
program
there's you know great academic programs
in the city of Chicago but the one with
the best rankings in the University
Health consortium every year for
clinical programs clinical care is
actually Rush University so now we're
able to so far we've been able to bring
in the business that allows us to take
care of the community
yeah that's great I mean basically what
I'm hearing is you have to you have to
be boots on the ground and engage these
can you know these communities by
meeting them where they're at like there
is there are there churches there at
there wherever the community centers are
and like and it's a one on one thing
really absence how you arrived change
that's beautiful yeah well your own
personal story is is super interesting
as well I mean you grew up south side
right through a relatively poor and have
you know made quite a life for yourself
but what I thought was really was really
interesting is like you're a tennis
superstar right you have that you know
you were thinking about going becoming a
professional tennis player well it was
actually my coach that was thinking yeah
tell me this story well you know it it
is it's interesting that I was a
championship chess player one of the top
but in the state of the Wow and at the
end of my junior year I was a kept on
the chess team and and my guys who who
were on the team at the end of chess C's
and said they're going out for tennis
and I just went with him so it turns out
that yeah I learned enough in a short
amount of time to actually become the
number three singles player even though
I had never picked up a racquet your
friends were like this guy good at
everything well no this is I mean it
would have been nice to have been
exposed to tennis in our early age
because most people are starting at age
four and five six and here I was 15 and
so as it turns out one of the schools
that we played Chicago vocational only
had one player and then that one player
actually told us that there was a
program designed for inner-city poor
kids at the University of Chicago you
can see what's going to happen right and
so I said well I I should just go over
there so I got on a bus and went to this
program and I learned to play tennis
on a court with 60 kids and didn't have
I didn't really have rackets or anything
like that but I talked to the coach who
turns out he was african-american and he
was actually a sort of part-time
minority recruiter for the University of
Chicago and he was the varsity tennis
coach and so he had a tremendous impact
on me he actually got me an interview
which I didn't know was an interview at
the time until I applied to University
Chicago and I couldn't get an interview
and I called up and they said no you had
it back at already July I was I was
shocked I'm trying to remember
everything I said anyway I ended up
getting into University Chicago I
learned enough tennis there to go back
and play number one in my high school
but I still look this wasn't real tennis
so I went to the University of Chicago
and talked to the coach he says no
you're not gonna make this tennis team
but you know you're welcome to come to
practices and I was so determined you
know sort of two things one was making
that leap from Chicago Public Schools
with the reading skills to the universe
Chicago was a big difficulty and the the
one thing that would make me sit in a
wreath yeah sit and read Plato for hours
is if I played about six hours of tennis
then I could set right and so that
actually worked for me and so and of
course playing six hours of tennis you
actually get pretty good so barely made
the tennis team at the starting lineup
but I just barely beat out the number
six guy on the the day beef before the
matches began and so I actually did play
that year but I had gone to college a
little early so I was still 17 and I
that would within my first year of the
18 and unders if I had known that there
were tournaments which I didn't okay but
I found out about these tournaments and
I started playing them and I lost in the
first round of every tournament in the
Chicago district and so after the first
couple rather than just you know going
back home I figured out that what I
should do is figure out why I'm losing
and I actually would go to the draw
after after my
go to the draw look at the top to seed
see who they were see where they were
playing and hang around until I watched
them play their matches and what was the
difference how are they constructing
points how do they hit the tennis ball
to everything and it turns out that I
learned so much by the losses and the
observation that I went back to
university cago with nobody graduating
and I won I beat everybody so probably
number one so then my tennis career
started taking off once you're the
number one singles player then you can
teach lessons on the side okay then
you've actually got a stream of income
and and so one thing led to another so
my coach really after I got applied to
medical school and there's this sort of
the last free summer of your life
there's between freshmen and sophomore
year and I had had a tough year
right between college and med school in
terms of not understanding what you
understand very well the the intensity
of playing pro tennis was not something
that was ready for and I would cramp up
then you know be up you know a break in
the third set after my fourth match and
I just couldn't never got beyond the
quarters of any of those pro tournaments
so then that next year I focused on the
fitness I really did and I was training
every day I was in I incorporated into
my teaching or teaching big junior
development groups and you know I would
try to win that three-mile race every
single day needless to say I did not
lose based on fitness anymore and I had
a really good year and at the end of
that year at the American Tennis
Association national championships after
I had beaten the number one seed they
there my coach was just pressuring me
don't go back to medical school go on to
pro Turk Pro Circuit and you know I look
back at that so what did and then say
would I yeah because it was a tough
decision
the good fortune for me is that I got
injured I'd semifinal match and and so I
really couldn't play for about six weeks
and so I would have missed the US Open
this was a qualifier from the US Open
which would have launched me into I
don't know what you know no sponsorship
you we eat what you kill essentially and
without the price money you don't do
very well so as it turns out I did go
back to medical school and and when I
think about it I really wouldn't give up
one year okay Iraq that's not one at
which for for pro tennis I love tennis
it's a wonderful sport British Journal
of Medicine says that it has a 47
percent decrease in cardiovascular
mortality there you go to be a tennis
player so I really been a benefit to me
and you kept me focused and kept me
exercising but it's it's it's not
something that would have given up
medicine he made the right choice I
think so and then you got to sounds like
you're your son became quite the player
he did he did and my son is a as a
Marine
and he actually feels very strongly
about we you know coming coming out of
high school going into college soon
after 2009 11 he wanted to actually go
and you know go into the Marines and and
I say that he'd used all that tennis
training the idea of getting up at 5
o'clock in the morning it might have
been foreign to the rest of the guys in
the room but not for him because that's
because he had been doing that since he
was 8 9 years old as a tennis player you
know being able to think strategically
and do hard physical tasks that's I
think it's we you know I don't know if
he'll decide what but I think that's
what made him listen up the Marine that
he is and how he's a he's a he's a great
guy very cool well uh I know I gotta let
you go here soon but I can't let you go
I don't a skillful last one so the first
question I wanted to ask is you know I
always like to give people some simple
takeaway so if somebody's listening to
this you know they're one of those
people who's been mired and the
confusing morass of conflicting
information that's available out there
they're just looking at me like just
just tell me just just give me like the
thing I should do first or what's the
what's the most important thing is it
exercises a diet is it is it dairy is it
meat is a process you like just give me
a couple marching steps that I can
easily digest and implement into my
I really we would like to have more
comparative data but we have some and it
does say that that principle that you
can't exercise your way out of a bad
diet there's some truth to that I mean
you can mitigate a bad diet but you
can't you're gonna have a bad outcome
ultimately it's not gonna solve you and
so I would say that nutrition is the
most important decision that we can make
if we could change one thing it would be
to have heart-healthy information coming
out and and have that be a real
definition and so for the individual
patient finding out where they are and
seeing what are the elements that are
going to create more and more diseases
similar to what brought them to my
office in the first place and and I
understand that that's this is not
primary care this is a nun family
practicing you know these are people who
already have heart disease when they're
seeing me and so I have a little easier
job because they're already motivated
the fact that they're in my office means
that they're motivated to try to make
some kind of change they're expecting to
come out of there with something
different that's gonna change their
outcome not every physician has that
advantage but it's something that we all
should take advantage of because you
know yeah almost everyone is having you
know a family member who suffers from
heart disease or has had heart disease
or has sudden cardiac death and so just
trying to get them to understand that
there is a relationship between your
lifestyle and your outcome just make
that connection if we can do that we
would all be so much better off right
it's a great answer and the final one if
you were to wake up in some strange
parallel universe to find yourself the
new Surgeon General Wow what's the first
thing that you put in motion I said
that's a that's a good one you know
previous Surgeon General was a good
friend of mine Regina Benjamin and she
was very concerned about she's
african-american as you recall and it
was very concerned about delivery of of
health care and getting health equity
I would I would really want to continue
the momentum that that she had started
terms of getting people to understand
the whole impact of healthcare
disparities we actually and it's
interesting that you know that yeah it's
racial segregation and educational
depression and all sorts of things that
led to these health care disparities not
just genes okay
all of this can actually be improved by
lifestyle and if we could get that word
out there there was a wonderful analysis
of this published in circulation in 2015
called the regards trial if you look on
their website and try to find the paper
it's buried in like 200 publications
that they did just so so good at getting
stuff out there but the regard study was
looking at racial and ethnic risk for
stroke and what they found is not just
stroke a stroke heart attack and death
and it is related to diet in that
southern diet that the African America
you know southern meaning the southside
of Chicago as far as I'm concerned
because that's what we were eating there
that diet is so damaging that if you
could just fix the nutrition the gap in
healthcare disparities would change
almost on a dime hmm dr. Kim Williams
you're an inspiration sir my pleasure I
really appreciate your having me yeah
thank you so much please keep doing what
you're doing
spreading the healthy powerful message
that you do we need you and we need more
people like you so thank you very much
and thank you for all that you're doing
it's my pleasure if people want to
connect with you online where's the best
place to find out information I mean you
know the the rush website that would
imagine the rush website has each of the
faculty members and you know there's
actually a one of our faculty members
Jeff so we'll just put up a whole thing
on plant-based nutrition it was really
wonderful to see that and we are have a
big presence there if they just google
can they Williams MD you'll get a few
million hits and a couple of them are my
my son who's a neurosurgeon first out in
practice oh wow I'm sure in the next few
years he'll be taking over those
Google hits aha yeah it's a Kim Williams
senior can oh yeah right and you're on
Twitter at cardio 10s that's like a
tennis number 10s right so you hit him
up there
absolutely all right thank you so much
well hopefully we can have a will you
come back to talk to me some other time
absolutely sure I'm sure there'll be
more data
I'm hoping it's alright thank you these
planners
[Music]